we're going to start this newshour in
afghanistan where violence is getting
more intense taliban fighters are moving
towards big cities and provincial
capitals
government forces are struggling to push
back in kandahar
afghanistan's second largest city there
have been a series of rocket attacks in
the main airport and flights in and out
have been suspended
hundreds of military commandos have been
deployed to kharat in the west
there's heavy fighting outside that city
but the situation is particularly bad in
lashkar gab the capital
of helmand province there the afghan air
force has been blamed for bombing a
hospital
the city of 200 000 people is in a real
danger
of falling to the taliban charlotte
bellas has more from kabul
heavy fighting in and around three major
cities in afghanistan and lash kargar
the capital of hauman province fighting
started on saturday when the taliban
entered the city
residents said they could see the
taliban moving street to street getting
closer
to the heart of the city until afghan
special forces entered and since that
time
they said they've just heard heavy
gunfire and also air strikes
from afghan air force and also from
the united states peppering around the
outskirts of the city
there communications have been cut off
in lashkar-gas incredibly hard to get
information
in and out of the city and for residents
to feel secure not knowing what is going
on
around them in kandahar city the second
biggest city in afghanistan also heavy
fighting journalists they're telling us
they've heard constant gunfire for about
24 hours inside the city
the airport there was damaged by a
rocket attack
civilian flights were stopped but they
hoped to resume them
on monday but also u.s airstrikes and
afghan air force
striking there to support their military
on the ground
and thirdly in cad in herat city in the
west
that is looking a little bit better from
the government's perspective they've
managed to retake control from the
taliban
they sent in reinforcements and they
managed to push the taliban out further
and re-secure the airport allowing
flights
to resume for residents there now
president ghani held a cabinet meeting
where he
talked about the security situation
evolving he said he doesn't believe
that the taliban are interested in peace
and that securing cities
are their priority well the taliban has
taken more territory in recent weeks
than it did at any time since it fell
from power
20 years ago in may it controlled about
20
of afghanistan but as us and other
troops have been withdrawing it seized
the opportunity to ramp up its offensive
within two months half of the country
has fallen under taliban rule
the afghan government is now facing a
critical test
as the fighters advance and surround the
capital kabul
victor yurosevic is a medical
coordinator at the emergency surgical
center for war victims in the center
of la shkargar he says he hopes the
neutrality of his facility
will keep his team out of the conflict
the situation in las vegas city itself
security device deteriorated vastly
since last three days
especially yesterday in the afternoon
when we are seeing open clashes
inside the city close to the city center
we received 20 patients
mostly civilians nine patients
were arrived as dead on arrival and all
the city is now blocked
and we cannot predict the dynamics of
the
next days even hours different variety
of injuries
we have a mine shell bullet
so all of them are more wounded we had
to narrow down criteria of admissions
now we are taking uh only
life-threatening
uh life-threatening conditions so we
only admit for the life-saving surgeries
as our bedrock capacity reached
more than 90 percent and in this case we
need to narrow criteria just for the
realization life-saving procedures we
have a stock for three and a half months
of all supplies
except of uh critical items that we try
to
to get from our center in kabul
now of course with communication and
transportation that is cut off
is going to be an issue in the next days
as well
in this moment uh there are no any
tensions around the facility itself our
main goal is neutrality
so we treat everybody as same we don't
ask questions we don't uh
we don't ask who is from which party and
we hope this neutrality
will help us to survive in the
in the next period